[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
all the awesomeness going on
at Google in the last week that
developers care about, but may
have missed.
First let's talk about the
coolest video I saw this week,
the Google Data Center
360 degree tour.
The tech in these data
centers is amazing.
And this video gives
you a full cinematic VR
experienced by Sandeep,
a developer advocate
on the Google Cloud platform.
And just for fun, watch
the video using Cardboard,
and try to spot the Google
security guard in every shot.
It's like a highly
secure game of Where's
Waldo with a backdrop of
the coolest scaled computer
architecture ever.
The Node.js runtime on Google
App Engine is going beta.
Combining Node.js and App
Engine gives you a great way
to build web apps
and mobile backends
with JavaScript that also need
to operate at Google Scale.
Check out the post
to get started.
The Google Code Jam is back.
Now, this year is the
13th annual algorithmic,
global coding competition.
If you like programming,
winning, and competing
for the $15,000
grand prize, make
sure to sign up before
the online qualification
round on April 8.
The Game Developers Conference
happened a couple weeks ago,
and we hosted our
annual Developer Day
where we announced new
platform and ads tools
for developers of all sizes.
This post rounds them up,
including one of my favorites,
Search Trial Run Ads.
Now when users search
for your games on Google,
they can get an
ad with a Try Now
button that allows them
to play your game right
there for up to 10 minutes and
then download the game in full
if they choose.
It's a great way
to get users who
are likely to stay engaged
with your game after install.
Now, since it's tax season
for those in the US,
I thought I'd also
share this article found
on opensource.com.
Turns out Senator Daniel
Squadron and Senator Ruth
Hassell-Thompson
have put forth a bill
in New York that will provide a
tax credit for 20% of expenses
associated with the
development of open source
and free software up to $200.
Now, let's hope this passes
in New York so all you
New York open source developers
can upgrade your gear.
And perhaps other states
will catch on too.
If you've been watching
this show for a while,
or saw my chat with Josh
Gordon a couple months back,
you know that we're all really
excited about machine learning.
Last week at GCP Next 2016,
we announced the alpha release
of Cloud Machine Learning.
It's a framework for building
and training custom models
to be used in
intelligent applications.
It allows you to build
large-scale machine learning
models on your data
using TensorFlow.
In addition to the deep
learning capabilities
and the power of Cloud
Translate API, Cloud Vision API,
and Cloud Speech API,
we provide easy to adopt
samples for common tasks like
regression and classification.
Check out the post for all
the links to get started.
And those are your
updates for the week.
Click the links
in the description
below, like this video, and
don't forget to subscribe.
After all, you don't want
to be the developer who
misses the coolest new platform
updates across all of Google,
right?
Of course you don't, which is
why I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]